[音楽]
こんにちは
ブルキャリーリストの首藤真由香です
皆さんという言葉聞いたことありますか
ないですよねというのは私が作った言葉だ
からです
ブリリアントという
素敵な輝いているという
英語の意味を入れたブリリアント
ライフビリアントキャリアの略で一人一人
が
充実したキャリアとライフスタイルを実現
し人生を100%楽しむという意味です
本日は自分の人生の経験から先ほど留学の
おすすめがありましたが私はブリキャリア
のおすすめをお話しします
私の家庭は父がペンキ族で
小学校まで北側福島から南が北九州まで6
回の転校しました
学校を転校するために私になれるかなと
不安だったんですけども公立の学校は
もともといろいろな家庭環境の子供が
混ざっているのでわりと自然と溶け込む
ことができました
そして中学で慶応中等部に入りその後大学
まで慶應だったんですが
中等部では女子の同級生は約半分が
幼稚舎出身だったり他の子も
有名な進学塾出身だったりと共通点が多く
地方の小学校から入ったのは私ともう一人
だけでした
そうするとやはり自分は少数派だなという
意識が強くなり学校生活においては自分の
個性よりも周囲を合わせようとしている
ことを優先した記憶があります
その後女子校に進み
入学直後に学校の掲示板で
海外交換留学というポスターを見つけまし
た
私は実は
海外ですらその時行ったことなかったん
ですけどもなぜか留学したい強く思って
反対する両親を説得して無事
オーストラリアに
交換留学することができました
留学先の投稿は
イスラエルを中心に海外からの移民も多く
さらに
留学支援団体が
企画するイベントでは数十カ国出身の
留学生仲間と交流する機会がたくさんあり
ました
当時彼らからよく聞かれた質問というのは
実は日本とか日本人だけではなくて実は
私自身の生活環境とか
価値観についてでした
それまで私はあまり考えたことなかったの
ですが彼らの質問を通して
初めて自分は何者か何を考えているのかを
意識するようになりました
そして私の話に対する彼らの反応は日本と
比較にならないほど多種多様でした
その多様な意見を聞いて私は一つの正解に
こだわる必要なくて一人一人がありのまま
でいるんだなと
認識で感じました
この交換留学を通じて私はいろいろ国の人
が共存できる世界づくりに貢献したいと
思ったのですが大学では今度は
ヨーロッパみたいなと思ってしまってまた
1年フランス留学しました
今思うと高校と大学で2年留学した人と
いうのは2年留年した人と同じくらい
希少かもしれないです
就職ではこれまた
少数派の
ヨーロッパ系の証券会社を選びましたが
その時にはもう周りの目のを気にすること
なく自分の価値観で行動できるようになっ
ていたのではないかなと思います
ところが仕事を始めてから私の行動原理は
また変わってしまいました
何においても仕事を最優先するいわゆる
マニキュアになってしまったのです
外資系の証券会社では入社早々とからプロ
としての貢献を求められるので早く成長
するためにいつも仕事仕事仕事と言われて
顧客の要望ならば土日も働けというのが
当時は主流でした
そしてその後に勤めたコンサルティング
会社による経験が私のバリキャリに拍車を
かけました
私はもともとのいろいろな国の人が共存
できる世界づくりに貢献したいという思い
を置き去りにして
周囲と比較して自分はどうなのか
上司や会社の期待値に見合ってるかばかり
を気にするようになっていたのです
そんな思いで仕事をしているとすごく胃に
息苦しくなり自分が期待するほど仕事の
成果も出すことができず
負のすらパイラルに入ってきました
そして13年前私は逃げるようにして
グローバルな自動化開始に転職しました
この自動車会社というのはちょっと変わっ
ていた特別な会社で日本の本社にも様々な
国籍や
勤務経験を持っている人たちがいろいろな
人生観やキャリアカーを持って働いてまし
た
例えばそれこそ仕事を最優先して
旬なのか24時間働いて早く昇進してお金
稼ごうという人もいたのですが
周囲のために
勤務時間を
勤務時間を最低限にして仕事の効率化に
励む人
さらに子どもを家族を大切にして子供の
バスケットボールの試合のためには早退を
してその後でまた仕事をする人など
仕事はきちんとしながらも人生の様々な
要素をそれぞれ大切にして生きている人
たちが多くいました
私はその自動車会社で大きな気づきが2点
ありました
1点目は自分自身についてです
いろいろな価値観を見たことで自分の価値
観は何だろうことで私は仕事も
趣味も家族も全てを大切にしたいという
ことが分かりました
そこでようやく売却バリキャリを脱却して
この
充実したキャリアやライフスタイルを実現
し人生を100%楽しむ
ブレーキキャリを追求し始めました
実際に今ですけども私の生活は仕事では
本業に加えまして本や雑誌の執筆をしたり
とある企業の社外取締役を務めたりさらに
コーチングをしています
仕事外の時間ではこの数年は登山にはまっ
ていて
日本百名山のうち55座を上っていたりと
かあと初心者ですが
スキューバダイビングやピラティス
バイオリンなども習っています
2点目の気づきは
組織や社会についてです
自分の
価値観を大切にしている人たちは生き生き
している
生き生きする人たちが多い
組織や社会は活気にあふれる
いろいろな価値観が共存できる多様性を
つくって
維持することがとても重要だと感じました
この自動車会社に私は9年間いたのですが
この9年の間に日本に住む外国人は増えて
さらに
就職や転職の時の選択肢で
有名な大企業だけではなくて
スタートアップやフリーランスも浸透して
きました
この同質性の高い日本のようやく多様性が
浸透してきたかなと思った私は
日系の
スタートアップに転職してその後は今は
日経が経営アドバイザリー会社で働いてい
ます
ところが
一旦日本企業に入ってみると実態が違う
ことが分かりました
出身の国どころが
勤務経験どころか人口の半分を占めている
女性すらも活躍しきれていない
多様性が限られた状態だったのです
実際に世界経済フォーラムが毎年発表し
ます現代
医学指数を見ても日本は146カ国中
なんと116人となります
内訳を見ると
教育では1位と男女の差はないのですが
経済では121位
政治になっては139位と
低い順位にとどまってます
日本政府や企業は様々な取り組みを通じて
女性の活躍を推進しようとしていますが
浸透のスピードは決して速くありません
そこで私はブリキャリアを提唱し始めまし
た
ブリキャリは本来国籍も性別も
バックグラウンドも一切ではない
コンセプトですが現在は女性を中心に
コーチングを通じて伝えようとしています
その理由は自分の人生やキャリアの満足度
を高めたいと思っていても
結婚したら
男性が働いて女性が家事やるべきだよねと
か
子育ては女性が主にやるべきだよねと
意外と女性の役割に対する
規制概念を持っているのが女性に多いから
です
それと同時に自分の人生をもっと良くし
たいモヤモヤしたいモヤモヤしてると思っ
ているのも女性の多いです
皆さんも周りの方に
良かれと思われこんなことを人生を送った
方がいいよと思われることも多いかもしれ
ません
しかし私は誰かに言われるのではなくて
自分自身が幅広い選択肢を持ってその中
から自分の価値観で行きたい生き方や
キャリアを選んでいく
プリキュアに自分の人生は自ら家事を取る
ということを後押しすることで私は今まで
は風呂場な環境での多様性にの恩恵を受け
てきたんですけども今後は
一人一人の価値観が共存できる社会づくり
に貢献していきたいと考えてい
ますご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]